this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money and your
life
i'm john delonie joined here by my good
friend to ramsey personality george
campbell and we are taking your calls on
life on money on relationships on what
to do next this is your show america
this is your show
these are your challenges that you're
walking through and lucky for you george
and i are stumbling through our lives as
well fans have clamored for this dynamic
duo john and we are back yeah and you
can you can uh we have a packed house
out there in the lobby just one sweet
man out there it's so great
hey there's nothing like a guy who says
you know what it's wednesday i don't
even i'm not even going in i'm not even
going into work i'm gonna go hang out
with george and deloney they're at the
ramsey's
you're winning at life
this is how you know you're winning this
is how you know but it is fun it's fun i
always love doing the show with you uh
with your prowess in the the mental
health arena relationships and my
knowledge of basic math we can conquer
the world
we can do this hey sir tell me about uh
you had a big event last night how'd it
go we did it was the game plan live
stream it was myself christy wright dave
ramsey and i kind of opened it talking
about goal setting and really goal
success because i've had a lot of goal
failure in my life and so i've done a
lot of digging a lot of research and i
tried to unpack it for the for the
audience and of course christy wright
came up to talk about balance and
priorities how to do the right things at
the right time and actually fit all
these goals into your life and of course
dave uh closed the night with the game
plan just went full dave budgeting
getting out of debt generosity and he
slayed as he usually does and it was a
great time we had a few hundred people
in the room with us we had tens of
thousands on live stream and i hope a
lot of lives were touched and helped and
people feel like they can get back on
the horse so you mentioned that you've
got some experience with failure i i've
never i've never experienced that so
what do you only achieve john
george well we've talked about goals a
lot and identity-based goals and james
clear his book atomic habits and how
helpful that has been because i always
thought it was all about outcomes i was
always focused on just the goal and
achieving that success and i never
really stopped to think about starting
with identity first the person i wanted
to become yeah not just what i wanted to
accomplish and then actually creating
systems processes habits around those
things i was like oh you have to do that
too there's action involved i just
thought you could write it down on paper
and then it would happen eventually what
i found is when i write a goal down
you've done more dig into this than i
have when i write a goal down and that
becomes this
psychotic focus for me
i start cutting corners and other things
i start not doing things let's so let's
say like i got to make this much money
by the time i'm this this this
old i will stop showing up and stuff
with my kids because i'm going to hit
that number i will take a third job when
i really don't need to be
i've become so single focused
single-minded on this goal
that the things that actually matter and
that bring me life
they go by the wayside instead of
looping back and i love the way james
clear says that who are you
yes you want to get to a bench press
number or a goal weight but start with
i'm a person who stewards their body
and that tends to shift
by degrees
i'm not gonna eat that donut today right
i'm gonna stop with two cups of coffee
instead of 17. i'm a person who honors
my body
the weight takes care of itself right
yeah and it's much more sustainable that
way the outcomes naturally happen as a
byproduct of the person that you want to
become and the habits that you've
created the disciplines because what i
found is motivation runs out real fast
so i'm real excited at the start and
people experience this with debt payoff
and they go okay i'm done with the
second job i'm done with the sacrifices
i'm done cutting expenses i just want my
life back and they fall off the wagon
and so creating those habits and those
disciplines remembering your why having
accountability having tools in your tool
belt like ramsay plus or podcasts or
total money makeover whatever that might
be for you is so crucial to getting here
and you have the we have the debt free
screams and most of them say what it
took is we went through fpu yep
as a couple and that's what got this
thing started so there has to be this
outside force that sometimes uh is the
the ignition that starts things for you
and then you can carry on because of
your why and because of the habits and
so it's powerful stuff uh we talk about
the wheel of life that zig ziglar coined
and how we've got to be balanced and you
talked about this just a moment ago but
you get a flat tire and i made this
reference of hey if you never skip leg
day but you skip all your son's soccer
games you're a really strong dude and a
really weak dad yeah yeah
that's not a place you want to be and so
christy was so helpful in setting those
priorities i want to let people know you
can actually go back and watch the
replay on the ramsay show youtube on
dave's facebook page so go watch this
it's about an hour and a half sit down
with your spouse if you've got one if
you're kind of like where a lot of
people are when they go 18 months
there's been a lot of failure a lot of
set goals and a lot of things not happen
yeah so
what's it like transitioning to
stage man like you're doing a great
great job thanks awesome thank you know
i'm learning from from you guys i'm
taking cues from dave and christy and
you and really wanting to take this
message to to our audience and to our
fans and do it in a fresh way in a way
that only i could do it hopefully right
from a younger kind of millennial
perspective someone who was in debt who
paid it off who now you know my wife
works here so we're so dunked in the
ramsey plan and so i'm just fired up i'm
like we got to get everyone on this we
got to get all these people who are
ramsey-ish you you've heard this i'm
dave ish
and when they go all in you get
exponential change exponential growth
and that's what i want for people
listening just before just for this is
some inside baseball here but um george
and i were getting ready to come out um
to do this show and
he has ramsey underoos on and it's
uncomfortable back there in the chain
not a thing but it's not a thing but you
know if we made them people you know if
you build it they will come they would
they absolutely would man
um so what things are you working on
right now so we've got the fine print
podcast is the thing that i'm most
excited about we just released an
episode about cryptocurrency trying to
help people understand it and how this
falls into your financial plan because
it's just you can't stop hearing about
cryptocurrency that's because all of the
world's economic systems are going to
implode and we have to move it all to
digital zeros and you've been reading
the same articles they have john
well duh don't you know it's just basic
uh common sense that we're gonna have no
more no more money george it's gonna
replace the dollar by tomorrow by
about four or five this afternoon i
think oh my goodness it's already that
time in another country so exactly
already happened yeah so we explored
this topic in 30 minutes in a narrative
storytelling way we have some experts on
we have real life stories a 17 year old
kid who can't remember the password to
his computer and now is locked out of
462 000
worth of cryptocurrency it's pretty wild
stuff so uh i encourage you guys go
listen to this where and again this is
not an anti-crypto episode we're not
here to bash crypto i think it has its
place i just don't want it to replace
your 401k and your roth ira and your
retirement plan this can be fun money
like if you're going to vegas or you
want to put a little bit of your
entertainment category there once you're
out of debt and you're already investing
15
that's fine
the conversations i'm hearing around
any number of things i don't want to
just focus on crypto
but they all stem
from a place of
fear and it's all coming down and so
it's people hedging and i with without a
doubt the crypt is a terrible hedge it
might be a monetary uh replacement it
might be something that you that you
play with right but as a
this will help me if this all falls
apart it's it's a poor thing
and we are always telling people
two things number one the tortoise
always wins tortoise like making a
a series of of
small repetitive habits that you do
every single day just gets you where you
want to go
it's not gonna get you there fastest
it's not gonna get you there in the the
shiniest car it's always gonna get you
there and
and nobody makes good decisions with a
panic nobody makes good decisions trying
to avoid calamity
you make good decisions when you're
calculating your measure that's why i'm
so happy that the fine print podcast
you're putting out there's is out there
in the world it's giving real
information
in a controlled way
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five protecting your calls on money on
life and relationships mental health
marriage anything you got going on in
your life give us a shout
i'm john delonie joined here with my
good friend george campbell let's go out
to alex in louisville kentucky and
louisville what's up alex
hey guys how are you outstanding how are
you man uh hanging in there
good deal brother so how can we help man
so um
basically my question is how do i get my
wife to start dreaming again um we're
about a hundred and ten thousand dollars
in debt
and uh that's the
i actually we've talked about it paying
all this off and really getting with it
and
getting this out of our life but
this the other day i finally sat down
and actually truly totaled everything up
not just i think it's about this and
this and this
so that's when i came up with just over
a hundred ten thousand dollars and hey
stop right there
put me in put me in your seat man was
that was that a scary moment
yeah i mean you know it was it was
bothersome to begin with but i mean
i didn't think it was that many digits
yeah uh
and uh you know it really made it
bothered me so much the other day i mean
i just i couldn't work and i mean i
talked about it non-stop
i mean i've never really had any
problems with anxiety or panic but i
think that's the closest thing to a
panic attack that i've ever had
absolutely and um so
i'm i'm ready to you know take on
another job there's fedex and ups over
here and i mean they're pretty flexible
and they actually pay pretty decent i
mean that'd be a whole nother 30 000 we
can add to the pile
a year but you know when i bring that
idea up it's uh well i don't want you to
get another job because when i you know
we get home you know i really need your
help with the baby and
um you know she could see herself
through my eyes she'd know that i mean
she's an awesome mom and uh i thought i
was an awesome dad and for being a
first-time dad and then
she comes home when i have him for the
day and he still wants to go to her so
she's that good well how old's your baby
nine months yeah brother don't take any
that personal man that
i i lost a lot of sleep and um
a lot had a lot of heartache over the
first with my first child um
wanting mom instead of me and i thought
it was because i i wasn't as good as her
and i was i was screwing something up
not the case man um that baby's
got a lot of stuff going on that does
nothing to do with you so um don't take
that stuff personal so have you sat down
with your wife
i can hear it in your voice
like yeah the word i would use to
describe what i'm hearing is scared
like this is the first time this thing
got real
does your have you sat down and told
your wife that you're scared you're
scared for your future you're scared for
y'all's small family any more kids are
going to come along does she know what
this is actually doing to the inside of
your guts and inside of your heart
i don't think she knows
bad i mean i just think she knows it
bothers me but yeah i grew up in a you
know family where we just said just make
the payment man just make the payment
man just make the payment and uh
and i mean i really and to this day my
mom and dad god love them are still like
that sure
i don't want any of that and i don't
want any part of it
i am oh you know admittedly i am the
spender but uh
you know she that's where she's kind of
the anchor to all this she really helped
bring a lot of that in
if i could i feel like if i could just
get her to dream with me and see that it
bothers me
um i would you know we would actually
you know get somewhere but i don't know
how to even how do i have that
conversation
where it's productive and that it
actually you know i don't want to say
the wrong thing and you know come off as
you know being a jerk or yeah yeah
totally so i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you part of it and then
george is gonna walk you through the
back half of the plan part i think
there's two two keys here
you you're right sitting down and
painting a picture together of what the
future could look like if you guys got a
hold of your finances a hold of your
communication
a hold of being on the same page when it
comes to raising your kid what does time
look all that is extraordinary
the the the path into that is
vulnerability for you
it is sitting down and looking at your
life because right now she thinks this
is like you're annoyed like your
favorite football team is losing you
know what i mean she just has dumped
this over into things that husband rants
about
not
hey i'm having a panic attack my heart
is my body is starting to revolt on me
because i'm scared so you get a
babysitter which is gonna be hard for a
nine month old you'll get a babysitter
and you go out somewhere
and you sit down and say hey this is
gonna be a tough conversation i'm gonna
be honest as i can with you and probably
in a way you never have
and i'll tell you if you're speaking
from the heart and you were talking
about you not her you're not going to
say the wrong thing if you make this
into an attack mode and you go after her
then that's just nonsensical and silly
this is about your heart right now and
you let her know honey i did all the
math and we're 110 grand in the hole
and i'm scared
and the only way out of this thing is
sacrifice we aren't safe we've put our
baby in a position um in a vulnerable
position we put our marriage in a really
precarious position
and in the second part of this thing
is a plan and so george can walk you
through hey here's what here's what this
actually looks like because you've come
to your wife and complained about stuff
before you've ranted and raved about
stuff before and then she's rolled her
eyes and moved on because that's the
right response to someone just ranting
raven about nonsense the second part of
this is saying
and here's the plan yeah
so let's dig into some of the financial
part because i think part of this is you
do need a why like john's talking about
you need to have that conversation with
her on a date night and go hey let's
dream about what our future could be
because right now it's obviously our
present is not great and so i think
getting her to dream about that
aspirational future and then coming up
with a plan to get there and sometimes
that takes math where you go hey look
how much we're paying an interest look
how much of our money is going to
lenders every month and once you do that
she may get fired up and if you guys
haven't
been through financial peace university
something where you can get on the same
page i'm happy to gift you guys a year
of ramsay plus where you can dig in that
but what is your your household income
right now
uh
right about 120. 120.
okay great income there and you have
110k in debt what kind of debt is this
so it's a little bit of a mix of student
loans uh we have home repair loans about
30 that's for a mold remediation
foundation worth
combo
and then that one hurts huh that one
hurts
oh yeah it really hurts
nothing like buying a house that you
love to find out it's got stuff grown in
it it's falling apart
that one hurts it's supposed to be taken
care of on the on the buy but it was not
and the contractor closed the business
so
that really hurts um
so uh there's that and there's a
some a personal loan there and then i
think about 15
or yeah 15 000 in a uh truck loan the
other card is paid off okay okay
well
you've got a great income here and uh if
you guys can you're saying you're
willing to take on the side job to make
this happen right
oh yeah i've done it before i'll take
three
jobs i mean i don't care but i don't
want to do that because i want to do
whatever you do together
yes
make sure you're on the same page with
it but if you let her know hey this is a
temporary sacrifice to get us out of
this mess uh and here's the expectations
i'm gonna be gone two nights a week
three nights a week whatever that may be
um and we're going to clean this up six
months faster if i do that i think that
will help you guys start to dream
together but i think if you can live on
you know a portion of your income you
can get rid of this debt in two years
following our plan most people can do
this in baby step two do you have any
money in savings any cash right now
uh yeah we did just a thousand dollars
so that was part of where we kind of
sort of i've
you know followed you guys for a little
while until
without calling it the dave ramsey plan
yeah you know i tried to start to
introduce it but without the dream it
just seems like you know like at least
we'll fall forward
well you hang on the line i'm gonna have
kelly pick up and gift you guys a year
of ramsay plus and what i want you to do
is get on the every dollar budget you've
got you'll get every dollar plus through
that and you'll get access to financial
peace university just make a commitment
sit down start to watch some of those
videos dream together find that why
develop a plan and show her that you can
get out of this in under two years
i think they do in 18 months 100 he's
willing to work for it yeah if he's able
to get that second job and he's making
150 000 a year they owe a hundred and
100 grand 110 100 off 55. if they could
look for spartan for a year they can
knock this thing out quick
um
i get that question a lot
how do i help them
and the reality is
all we can control at the end of the day
is our thoughts and our actions the
things that we do the things that we
choose to think about and ruminate on
and spin out on
and so often instead of saying how do i
get them to get on board
it's
how do i invite them into what i'm
feeling and that's sitting down saying i
am scared to death
and i got a plan
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your calls on life and money let's go
out to quinn in columbia south carolina
hey quinn what's going on
oh nothing much it's really really good
to talk to you guys youtube my brother
what's up how can we help
so i am a 20 year old student uh in yeah
i'm a student i'm in a university
studying computer science and i am
making a little bit more money than i
expected to at this point um i have two
two jobs one is as close to full time as
you can get uh in school
and then i've got another little
freelance development thing that i do on
the side and then i'm also a ta so i've
got three streams of income and
two of them are pretty substantial so
now total
substantial to me means about 50 000
as a full-time student dang gina that's
substantial to all of us man
congratulations yeah
yeah thank you thank you so uh and of
course that's pre-tax but um you know
i've gotten into the habit of every
paycheck i take a thousand dollars off
the top and i put it in my investment
account so i've been doing that for a
while and uh about you know the better
part of a year
and so well i guess not to be at almost
almost six months i should stay because
i've got a little over ten thousand
dollars in there now wow and um and and
i'm getting to the point where uh it's
about to go up a little bit more and so
um i don't know like i just opened up my
roth ira and essentially what i want to
ask you guys is as a 20 year old how can
i best set myself up going forward um
you know after this i'm in my last year
so next you know about may of next year
i'm going to start working full time and
i'll be making more then so i'm just i'm
kind of looking for general direction as
opposed to just saving because i feel
like that's kind of you know that's kind
of not tapped out but like there's only
so much i can get you
to everybody listening to this call
let's turn over to george to everyone
listening this call who's complaining
about the
next generation and these kids don't
work hard and they don't do
everybody take notice of quinn
because there's some ballers out there
who are absolutely grinding and getting
it done man quinn you're an inspiration
and i'm grateful for the call man what a
absolute stunt dude that's awesome who
taught you this thank you
uh um
i mean my dad's an entrepreneur he got
laid off so he started a company um and
so that that was a big inspiration for
me my parents always been you know my
whole family really has been pretty
fiscally responsible and uh just here
and there i've had i've had mentors that
you know especially like my uncle is one
he always he pays every dime
but you know he's going to retire at 55
he's going to live a good life
afterwards so um i don't know it's kind
of just been a culmination of my
experiences
at 20. and everybody else listening to
this your kids are watching you they're
not listening to you they're watching
you you want to create children like
quinn do right by your money do you
right by your relationships work hard
you get laid off step up and create a
job for yourself good job to you quinn
shout out to your family george what in
the world should this guy be doing well
you're already crushing it and so we
tell people to you know why you're in
college to be investing in yourself
obviously you're already investing
you're doing great i want to make sure
that you can get through college
debt-free is that the case
yes sir it is yeah my family's been able
to cover that for me fantastic and you
graduate next year
yes sir i'll graduate in may awesome so
once you're out of college you'll be
making a lot more money and we teach the
process called the baby steps i'm not
sure if you're already familiar with
that but do you have any debt whatsoever
you're completely debt free no
no sir completely debt-free and do you
have a fully funded emergency fund i
assume you don't have a ton of expenses
right now as a student
no i know i have no personal expenses to
myself apart from uh you know if i want
to go out or anything that's not
essential to school i don't do much
because i don't have a ton of time left
over but i do have uh about twenty five
hundred dollars in my account right now
okay
so uh that would last me reasonably long
because i don't actually
you don't have many expenses okay that's
great yeah so your next move out of
college would be to get that emergency
fund in place because you're probably
going to be getting your own place an
apartment or whatever you want to do
there so your next thing would be making
sure you're investing 15 of your
household income into
investment accounts retirement accounts
which i don't think you're going to have
a problem doing you're going to have
that margin and you're already starting
to do that which is great a roth ira is
a great start uh to max that out and
depending on your career and your
workplace you might have a roth 401k
option
and that's a great place to go as well
and if there's a match obviously you're
going to be taking that as well so
you're going to be fine on the
investment part after that you know
you're not going to have kids in the
next year or two so you want to focus
maybe on what does it look like for me
to get into a house that uh i can afford
maybe you could pay cash i mean a guy at
your age who's already doing this well
what an inspiring story if you could
save up and pay cash for a home in south
carolina if that's where you're going to
plant your roots so that's what i would
be doing is just uh stalking away as
much cash as possible after i've
invested that 15 into retirement you've
got that emergency fund in place but man
you're doing so well i'm just proud of
you and hey quinn one more thing
the temptation here
is because i know how your mind works
and you have a unique mind and that is
one of
of abundance mindset you see money
everywhere and you aren't afraid of hard
work
and then you think i want my money
working for me
it's just sitting here making fifty
thousand dollars here's what i want you
to do i want you to be really patient
you have a few months to get through
until you're done with college your
number one investment right now is quinn
it's getting out debt-free you're going
to be
annoyed shocked at how much it costs to
move and get suits for your new fancy
job or i don't know if you're going to
be working in in uh computer science you
may just be able to go get a bunch of
punk rock t-shirts and get through it
but um
getting set up in a new place all that
costs money and so here's what i want
you i want you to fast forward six
months after your first job
i want you to be in your new place
with a car that's reliable with clothes
i want you to be debt-free six months
after college does that make sense
yes sir so start thinking about it's
it's incredibly expensive to get a
moving truck and
to move if you're gonna be in south
carolina you may get a job in atlanta
you may get a job in new york los
angeles wherever you're going to go
i want you to get through that season
debt-free so sock this money away and
you're going to think ah it's not
working for me it is because you're
working a longer game here but you are
the best investment until you are in
that first job and then you're getting
paychecks and then man then we're then
we're um we're putting in the different
accounts and we're off at the races
there that what is what a stunt let's go
to jonathan in san antonio hey jonathan
what's up brother
hey i appreciate you taking my call you
got it man what's up
um
i'm 24 years old looking to purchase my
first home and i don't know if i'm kind
of crazy for doing what i'm about to do
so i wanted to get some insight from you
guys well let's define crazy you're
talking to two pretty stable guys so
great call jonathan at least one what's
up
great i appreciate it yeah well i'll
start
the home is 415 000
um my current annual income is 105.
um i don't have any debt
and that's kind of where i'm at right
now
i've got i mean of course i've got the
home i'm looking at
and i'm just trying to figure out
if what i've got going for me right now
is enough to afford what i'm about to do
how much cash do you have to put down
um i've got well that's if you want me
to be really honest the whole story is
the down payment will be a gift and it's
going to be about 85 000
so that's a start test so we get just
gifting you 85 000
that would be my father
wow
that's pretty rad
yeah it's a good situation so i'm very
i'm very appreciative okay so you've
already got that about what twenty
percent down there
yeah it'll be right at 20 or right about
20
that's great well that's gonna help you
avoid that private mortgage insurance
which is awesome are you putting any of
your own money into this as well
uh you know it was a thought i've got
about 30 or 40 000 available cash um and
then an additional i'd say 30 or 40 in
retirement funds um so i don't
know if i would if it'd be smart to use
some of my available cash towards this
now or if i should save it and continue
saving it would be smart to use the
liquid cash it would be dumb to touch
anything in retirement accounts so you
said you're 30 to 40 i would get as big
of a down payment as you can on that
house because that's going to do two
things it's going to lower your monthly
payment because you have way more equity
and you're going to be able to pay that
house off a whole lot faster because of
that you're going to have more margin
back in your budget so
is that on top of an emergency fund or
is that is that your emergency fund so
that that kind of includes i would say
that 30 000 is all i've got in cash
across mutual funds and available cash
flow i'd say i'd take about five to six
as an emergency fund out of that so okay
25. yeah to subtract that emergency fund
out use the rest on top of the down
payment and you're going to be in great
shape yeah do the math
i don't want you
i don't want you over leveraging
yourself as a 24 year old yeah you're
walking in with
it looks like you're about
yeah it looks like the math works out
it's a lot of housing make sure that
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay yeah on a 15-year
fixed rate you'll be in great shape man
way to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john delaney joined here by george
campbell we're taking your calls on life
and money let's go to sabrina out in
buffalo new york hey sabrina what's
going on
hi um i'm a senior in college and my
boyfriend's also a senior in college and
i guess two weeks ago we found out that
i am pregnant and last week i got
proposed to
and
we're kind of just wondering how do we
take care of our baby while we're still
graduating
and um how we like get started in
marriage
i was just telling somebody before the
show came on sabrina
that i've had a chaotic last few weeks
and i'm gonna retract that statement 100
so you're having a baby congratulations
and he proposed to you you don't sound
super excited tell me about that
oh i am i'm just i'm still kind of in
shock over the whole thing yeah i can
imagine so um
so what are you studying like
um i'm studying computer science
computer science okay and what's your
i guess did you say yes
oh yeah we said yes we're getting
married in december i'm super excited i
like um i plan on marrying like two
years from now just not now if that
makes sense
it makes total sense and
so
what's your fiance gonna do
um he's been a mechanical engineer um
we're super lucky because we kind of
both have job offers i mean i'm still
looking for the current offer i have i'm
gonna be making 130 and then he'll be
making 90s yeah outstanding outstanding
okay so drill down your question for me
you graduate you're a senior so you're
gonna graduate um in may is that right
yeah both of us are okay
um
and are you gonna be able to navigate
your final trimester's in school and
what's your what's your spring semester
going to look like
um i was really lucky i only have two
classes left but because of financial
aid i'm going to take 12 credits so i
was just going to take the easiest
classes i need to graduate cool
so i in that very seat as a dean of
students at several colleges i worked
with students in your situation
and so what i would recommend you do
is to go meet with the school health
clinic go meet with the dean of students
office whoever that that person would be
that would walk you through that
let them know
and um make sure everybody's on the same
page just your college resources you're
paying a bajillion dollars for those
resources so this is a great moment to
put those to use
um and you're gonna get y'all getting
married pretty quick right you're
getting married in just a few months
here in december
yeah
just because um me and wanna be married
right when the baby was about to pop out
[Laughter]
those are your words not mine i wouldn't
have said that but cool i'll let you
have that one um so
tell me
distill your question down for me it
sounds like you are just
it sounds like you were skiing and then
the skis float from under you but you
didn't let go of the rope and you just
get that face full of water for about
250 yards before you finally let go and
now you're bobbing in the water and
everything is like whoa everything's
changed
do you have a particular question or you
just want someone to walk alongside you
and say
we're rooting for you and you guys are
going to be doing great financially
um
you're going to be if you make some wise
choices financially now make some wise
choices on
we this is happening two years early
everything got accelerated but we're
gonna be highly connected we're gonna
get some premarital counseling we're
gonna make sure we're on the same page
both how we're gonna raise this baby how
we're gonna love this baby where we're
gonna live
and start to the word i want to to
infuse in your soul here is intentional
you're you're a computer scientist
you're married an engineer you all
intentionally build things i want you to
take that level of intentionality to
your relationship that's just been put
in hyperdrive
but beyond that you have a specific
question that we can help with or just
want us to to cheer you on here
um i think so i think both of us we're
gonna be graduating with i think thirty
thousand dollars of debt combined and we
were kind of just wondering um
if we should probably like
what we i guess like financially what we
should do in order to pay off this debt
because should we pay off this debt
immediately or should we wait until
we're kind of settled in what exactly
should we be doing
yeah
george can hop in here with with walk
you through the baby steps but
absolutely you're going to want to get
this thing out of your life as soon as
possible you're going to want to enter
into this new
season of your life as a wife as a mom
as a brand new
um computer scientist you're going to
want to walk through that life with as
few strings or attachments to
to um uh
other people as possible and yes knock
that dead out george walker through the
baby steps so we what we talk about with
the baby steps and baby step two you're
paying off all of your consumer debt but
because of the baby on the way we talk
about going in storm and stork mode john
so i want you to not pay off that debt
until the baby's here and baby's healthy
and you're healthy and everyone's doing
good and whatever pile of cash you have
then you can throw that on the debt and
with this income it's going to be gone
within a few months
after the baby's here regardless so do
you guys have any income right now are
you just full-time students
um i mean we work like when we work like
i guess not minimum wage jobs but like
slightly more than that just to pay a
rent because like both of us are on like
basically full financial aid to like
whatever
but we have to pay for like rent and
food and stuff okay and you're not going
into any more debt before you graduate
um like whatever like i cannot make this
year because of pregnancy if that makes
sense because like i don't know how much
money like i probably won't be able to
work next semester if that makes sense
yeah well as much as you can avoid going
into more debt that's going to be super
helpful as part of this process as you
bring a baby into this world and really
start your own your adult life a little
earlier than you might have planned so i
would suck up as much money as you can
until baby's here and if baby's healthy
and you've got that money sitting there
you can throw that on the debt but
either way you need to get really
focused on this debt because i want you
to focus on being great parents and
being great adults and not have this
other stress in your life if we got to
make payments to lenders
yeah
here's what we're going to do i'm going
to sabrina we're going to give you um i
was going to say i am but george is here
too so we are we're going to give you as
a baby gift we're going to give you a
year's subscription to ramsey plus
and i want you and your fiance
in the next few months i want you to sit
down and watch all of the financial
peace university lessons
i want you to walk through it together
and create an intentional plan about
what life is going to look like next
semester what life is going to look like
a year from now where you all might want
to live you've got job offers in hand
which as george said are phenomenal
offers
the way forward right now is a is a cold
water dose of reality a cold water dose
of
planning and high high intentionality
and then by the way when this baby comes
everything you think you've planned is
gonna go it's gonna blow up right babies
will do that to you and your life's
gonna change in dramatic fashion so the
intentionality stuff you can do up front
so stay on the line and kelly's gonna
get you a copy of that uh i mean it's
gonna get you a year subscription there
let's take one more quick call let's go
to dustin in indianapolis hey dustin
we're up against the clock so get right
to your question brother
uh yes i'm actually just going because
i've got trying to settle some debts i'm
trying to make a home purchase okay i'm
trying i've got three
lines of debt on my credit
i just tried to settle up with one today
before i called you guys and they're not
willing to
negotiate the price
and they're they're just not trying to
send me any information
at all i just don't know how to go about
getting it taken care of
do you have it in writing did you ask
for that all the specifics of that
i i asked them they they refused to give
me they refused to give me anything well
they're legally obligated to give you
that information you're holding a letter
that says you owe them this much money
though right
i don't have the letter i've got from
the uh
back from the credit real saying i do
i own this amount i mean this is back
from like 2018.
it's a few years i'm just trying to get
it get everything taken care of
well that's what's stopping you if
you're proactive you call them and you
put the ball in your court and you need
to make this on your terms and you say
hey i'm happy to work with you guys but
we've got to get some of these specifics
done and you need to follow the law and
so i need this mailed to me
in writing to tell me exactly how much
debt and what this debt was from and
then we can talk through a payment plan
of what we're going to do to get this
thing out of our life and i would make
sure that i
document the time and date that you made
this phone call who you talk to
what's the number you call make sure you
keep records of these these interactions
um and here's a hard reality
if they won't negotiate with you
you owe them the money
[Music]
usually they will but sometimes they
won't and you've got to pay your debts
off man yeah and that's your
responsibility and do not go buying a
house when you got this mess clean this
up first follow the baby steps do it the
right way you don't want to need this
added stress in your life that's an hour
in the books on the ramsay show george
it's good to be with you man let's do it
again all right we'll be right back on
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money and your
life
i am john deloney joined here by my good
friend george campbell and we are taking
your calls on everything this is your
show triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
i've spent the majority of my career
dealing with relationships and mental
health challenges and
parenting and everything in between how
to deal with bosses you can't get along
with how to deal with co-workers that
are just nuts
not that i'm speaking from a personal
experience that felt personal john i i
was only looking at you because you're
sitting at the desk with me uh and
george you have stepped into
this
this um
money expertise in a pretty unique way
man and you've been here for what eight
years yeah um
both
joining dave on live events and
absorbing this stuff practicing it and
your own way and now you've become a a
national expert in this stuff apparently
it's a true honor you know dave called
me the ramsey test tube baby because i
feel like i grew up here and i was
dunked in the ramsey way and i i didn't
grow up with this stuff john you know i
came out of college with thirty six
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and four thousand dollars in credit card
debt and i was normal and i just thought
uh this is normal this is average and we
had a debt-free scream yesterday and she
said the most profound thing she said i
was really good at managing debt and i
was terrible at managing money
and my head exploded i was like i've
never heard it said so eloquently and
that's america they're really good at
managing debt and so they feel like
we're winning we know how to do this
right i grew up watching my dad do this
with credit cards we're gonna move it to
the zero percent one and we move that
here and you're doing all these these
crazy beautiful mind math to try to make
your life work and we're winning right
we're winning you think you are yeah and
so uh when i started working here i went
you know what if i'm gonna work at this
place i don't want to work somewhere
where i don't fully agree with with the
principals and so i started to do them i
did the baby steps and i got out of debt
and i started investing in safer
emergencies and i realized how much
anxiety money was causing me that i
didn't even realize until you're on the
other side and so my wife works here
it's a beautiful love story we'll save
for another time
but we just had this big hairy audacious
goal to pay off our house in under three
years and that was back in 2019 and
thanks to this place and the principles
not because we're special or rich just
because we've followed a proven process
we're going to pay off our house in six
months that's cool in our early 30s and
i just went
i didn't think i could do this i thought
that's for other people that's for rich
people that's for people who make more
money than i do but man this stuff works
and i just want to spread the word that
it works and to help people avoid
falling for the traps out there and
that's what i'm doing with this new
podcast to find print so i'm just so
passionate about these principles and
the more people i can help the more i'll
feel like i've got some purpose on this
earth that's awesome so if you are
struggling with your marriage your
relationships your parenting your kids
going back to school
work relationships
or if you're trying to navigate this
you've been man i'm sick and tired of
looking at these bills and i can't make
the math work i'm great at managing my
debt i'm not great at managing my debt
i'm great at playing a shell game in my
own house
and it's a house of cards
yes and
millions and millions had come down on
top of them a few years ago and then
we've all had some
checks mailed out to us and
we're setting ourselves up for another
fun house of cards so give us a shout
triple 825-5225
before we go to the phones
um
george you talk a lot about you you like
talking to the millennials yeah my wife
tells me i was born in the wrong century
often
because you're an old man
when i joined well that but when i
joined this company
i didn't have social media i had a
ringside seat to years and years and
years of working alongside students and
their parents and high school kids and
college students
and i i just i knew man it's like
hanging out with drug addicts like i'm
not going to do that i remember when you
started and they were like yeah no
john's not on the internet i'm like how
how does he exist yeah and shockingly um
i had a great job and uh
was doing great professionally without
this
without sharing it to the world exactly
how is it possible i was able to eat a
meal all by myself without telling
anybody about it it was a lot of fun
um but this uh wall street journal
article came out the other day
facebook is some released internal
documents facebook knows how toxic
instagram is for teenage girls
um
one of the uh released internal
documents
has things like we know we make body
image issues worse for one in three teen
girls
um instagram increases the rate of
anxiety and depression these are from
internally released facebook documents
and if you don't know facebook owns
instagram
um among teens who reported suicidal
thoughts 13 of british users six percent
of american users trace the desire to
take their own life
to social media
and here's the thing
i've got a fifth grade i've got a sixth
grader now but last year in fifth grade
um just at a local public school my son
came home one day head held low
dad i'm the only kid in fifth grade
that doesn't have tick tock that doesn't
have social media and i sat him down
said son i've been telling you for years
that your parents are weird
and that this day would come and i'm
sorry um i i know that that makes you
the odd kid in class it turns out he
wasn't turns out parents we've connected
over that actually like oh man you want
your kids to connect with other real
human beings and
have uh real relationships
but the data is emerging
and
especially among my mental health
colleagues across the country
social media is destroying our children
and i can't say it any more emphatically
it's destroying our children i know that
we think we are helping them by giving
them these digital babysitters and
saying you connect with your friends and
this is helpful it is not george and
it's creating this all universe these
false realities it's hacking our our
internal
um neural chemicals and our our
fight-or-flight responses it's just
destroying children and it's not helping
adults either here's the sucky part
george i never had it until i got it for
this job
and then i find myself like my kids are
saying dad you want to come play i'm
like oh look kids and i'm scrolling
through this thing and i thought oh no
yeah i'm an addict too now it's a vortex
so what are some examples what are some
some
um i don't know some things you would
recommend to millennials to old now i
mean i'm you know
facebook's taking over for adults too 67
it's one of my my grandfather who's
still alive he's in his 90s when he
friended me on facebook in college i
remember thinking i'm done here like i
remember this probably
um what do you what do you
what do you recommend to folks to get
off this stuff and to reconnect with
human beings one of the biggest things i
found is that to remind yourself that
you
have control of who you follow no no you
don't george you can control that john
there's an unfollow button they send me
you know what the algorithm we've put
you through our computers whoever they
is we think you'll like these people and
they're usually right well you've been
advertised for you know supplements and
things that hey john you could be
stronger and more tan and all these
different things and one of the keys
that i felt that i could ever get more
tangible is you got to get away from the
comparisons that's where a lot of this
anxiety stress mental health illness is
coming from because you're going i'm not
there yet how come all my friends how
come all these people are living lives
so much better than mine my life sucks
yeah you gotta take a step back maybe
delete the app for a little bit and get
back to reality and so when you just
said delete the app millions of people's
eyes rolled in the back of their heads
i'm not doing it john not doing it i'm
not doing it here's my challenge
take social media off your phones for a
week take them away from your kids try
for a day i bet they couldn't do that
that's right for a day and i want you
and your kids this can be crazy i want
you all to talk to one another i want
you to interact with each other i want
you to look at your spouse and say hi uh
how are you
try that see what happens we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
everyone
needs health insurance if you're alive
and i assume you are since you're
listening i don't know we're not that
great george then you may have just died
in your chair listening to us but if
it's not you
if you're not dead this means you right
this is going great so far i'm also
great at reading too uh don't even think
of going without health insurance just
one medical emergency for you or a
family member could be enough to wreck
you financially that's why health
insurance is a must but don't jump on
the first crappy health insurance plan
you find either the wrong kind or not
enough or too much is almost as bad as
no health insurance at all you have to
get the right coverage for you and your
family for most healthy people a high
deductible plan is the best option they
have the lowest monthly premiums and you
can use your emergency fund to pay that
high deductible no problem or a high
deductible plan also allows you to save
money for medical expenses in a health
savings account and hsas come with all
kinds of tax and investing advantages
now if you have a lot of health care
costs due to an illness or disability
you may be better off with a preferred
provider organization or ppo with a ppo
you'll pay higher premiums but your
insurance will chip in sooner to help
you pay for medical care we want people
to have a choice about their health care
that's why we let ramsay team members
pick the health plan they need and just
like them you deserve to choose the best
insurance for you
ready to find the right health insurance
plan text health to 33789 that's health
seven eight h-e-a-l-t-h-33789 all right
let's go to ryan in toledo what's up
ryan how we doing man
hey i'm doing good outstanding what's up
man how can we help
all right so um
by the beginning of
2022 i'm thinking about paying off my
house
but i'm unsure whether i should or not
talk to the bank
and they absolutely said no
i'm like well i've kind of been noticing
dave ramsey and i'd like to be debt free
and they said no that's an absolutely
bad idea
what was their reasoning yeah i'm so
curious what are they so happy with this
we said we want to keep this loan alive
as long as possible
yeah absolutely yeah and uh you know i i
totally disagree with them i didn't take
the time to
you know really listen to them they said
i should talk to a financial advisor and
i just want to get your guys opinion
well walk us through your financial
situation what do you got going on how
much money is the payoff how much money
do you have in cash
um payoff is about 120 000
and
currently i have about 130 140 000 to
pay it off just straight up in cash
liquid
um
yes
ryan congratulations wow what do you do
for a living man
i currently buy and sell equipment
that's what i'm doing right now
very cool so where did this money come
from you've just been saving up and
saving up while making your normal
mortgage payment
um i had a business that i sold about
two three years ago and i've just been
uh
holding the cash back and just uh just
keep just keep putting those savings and
trying not to touch it man that's
awesome do you have an emergency fund in
place have you been following our baby
steps
um i have not ever followed your plan
um
i've been listening to you guys for
about a year but i have not followed the
plan
um
by the and that's kind of why i'm
waiting until the i could pay it off
right now but um i'd like to have you
know 30 or 40 000 sitting and sitting in
cash for an emergency fund but do you
have any other debt other than this
mortgage
that's it that's it
well in the baby steps where you would
be at right now is baby step four
because you've got all this cash sitting
there you've got plenty for an emergency
fund it may be too much to have 30 40 in
there we recommend three to six months
of expenses sitting in a savings account
for emergencies beyond that you need to
be investing have you started investing
15 of your household income into
retirement
um i have not i was kind of waiting
until this house is paid off and seeing
how much extra cash it had to
start investing and um i would need to
research more on what to invest in
because i've never i've never been
around any kind of investment
absolutely well be sure to start that
how old are you right now
35 okay so you've got time uh but you
definitely want to be investing in some
some good retirement accounts and we can
connect you with a smart investor pro
you can jump on ramseysolutions.com and
click on trusted pros these are the
people that we trust that are in your
area in ohio who can walk you through
all of your options make sure you're
educated on what to do with this money
but as far as the house payoff outside
of your emergency fund
i mean you're doing great man you can go
ahead and pay this thing off tomorrow
why do you need to wait till next year
we need to not pay it off and
i mean
why why would why would i not want to
pay it off i guess
to give the bank more money is one
reason yeah so
you know they they gave me the you know
usual spiel of building my credit score
and all that and i just i don't know
dude listen um i'm gonna tell you what i
would do if i was you if i
walk me through your numbers again how
much you owe in your house
120 120 and you got how much in the bank
uh right around 140 as of right now 140
right
now i'm telling you right now if i'm in
your shoes i'd pay that house off today
you have 20 000 emergency fund that's
three months for you right especially
with no house payment
yes yeah i pay that off today how much
do you make what's your salary
um i don't really know i just kind of
started a new business like two years
ago
so i'm gonna guess maybe fifty thousand
if that a year
well that changes things a little bit so
i
i mean how much did you pay in tax i
mean what did you report last year for
taxes
um
i would have to go back on my records on
that one i can't ryan you know how much
money you make no to be honest i have no
clue what i make uh in the last two
years that's one of those numbers you
should have in your head
just just to know
so if you make ten thousand dollars a
year then you're going to want a much
bigger emergency fund
if you're making 50 60 70 000 a year
that changes the equation
yeah i mean rough rough estimate i mean
30 to 50 000 years is what i bring home
okay
so you may want to have a little bit of
bigger emergency fund but
yeah the there is absolutely
no reason
to have a hundred and twenty thousand
dollar mortgage with a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in the bank absolutely
ludicrous have no payments do i need to
worry about raising my credit score do i
need to worry about you know anything
like that i mean i don't think about
this if you're never going to go into
debt again you don't need the credit
score because you only need the credit
score to get approved for debt
all the credit score is is a
relationship gauge about how good of a
dance partner you are with debt if i got
a million dollars and deposit it in my
checking account today my credit score
would not change
if i got a billion dollars in my
checking account today my credit score
would not change
has nothing to do with your wealth
it has to do with how good of a
dating partner
are you with death
it's nonsense
be done with dead brother
okay i mean i i i mean i think i thought
it was that simple you know i've
listened to several other people and it
was the same situation it's like well
it's a no-brainer but you know when it
comes to you individually you start to
question things so
no and and hey let's be honest if you
walk into a bank and the banker looks at
you like you're crazy and says man what
are you doing you're going to ruin this
of course that's scary yeah that
interest money you are paying them is
helping them build a nice big building
or just think
the chair that that person was sitting
yeah the problem is you know eight ten
years ago they had me in so much debt
that it was scary hold on let's flip
that around let's flip that around who
had you in debt
i will i i personally did but yeah yes i
i had myself in debt but and then you've
worked your butt off
you paid for the carpet you paid for
that chair they were sitting on you pay
for their phones they love you yeah
i want you to buy your own carpet in
your own chairs and your own phones
sounds good does sound good hey
congratulations man for a free call you
just paid off your house
george we're geniuses i can't believe
this is free john he's crushing it i'm
proud of this guy way to go so good ryan
what a stud hey
listen
[Music]
of course your bank's gonna tell you
know what you should probably have more
debt don't don't take financial advice
from a bank choose freedom choose
freedom congratulations ryan you're dead
free my brother
and find out how much you make too by
the way this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
dalony joined by george campbell let's
go out to alex in utah hey alex what's
going on
hey how are you outstanding brother
what's up
okay so i am a
teacher and instead of a pension my job
offer is a 401k
um but they don't do a match instead
they do a
straight 10 of my salary goes right into
my 401k does that count towards my baby
steps
uh for investing
great question so in your situation
you're saying it's just a forced savings
plan that 10 out of your paycheck is
mandatory to go towards this retirement
account
um it's on top of their like agreed
salary so it's uh additional 10
additional 10 on top of your salary
yes how does that work
uh basically
the way the school uh payrolls work is
they say this is the money that you are
uh going to be given and then uh on top
of that they uh to the side they also
say well this is the money we also give
ten percent straight into your 401k
account well this
how much money do you make
uh about 50 000
it's coming up uh it's gonna go up this
year as it does every year and you're
saying on top of that 50 they're giving
you more money but they're forcing that
into an investment account
yeah yeah wow that's interesting you
make 50 grand they just put five grand
every year into a retirement account for
you
yes well that's great cool deal that's
really neat
because that's mandatory uh from you
we would count that towards your
retirement but what i would do if i were
you is maybe discounted a few points
just because you're not in full control
of this and we want you to be in control
of your destiny and your choices when it
comes to investing so i might discount
it by percentage or two so you might put
in let's say six or seven
six or seven percent mainly income also
into a roth ira
yeah yeah absolutely can you add more
money to that 401k that you have
i
could um
would it be better to take the rocks and
put that into the 401k it's not a raw
401k it's it's just a regular floating
okay yeah i would open a roth ira and i
don't i don't think you'd get close to
maxing it out or anything like that but
if that's something you want to do
depending on where you're at in the baby
steps you can add more to that roth ira
for sure but the roth ira is going to
give you the most options where you're
in control of which mutual funds you can
choose in there
versus the the company 401k so that's
what i would do i'd put five six percent
and put that in the roth to get you to
15 total uh but that's a really cool
program they have i've never heard of
that where it goes on top of the salary
yeah yeah it's pretty good that's great
so are you
as far as baby step four goes do you
have kids are you looking to do baby
step six pay off the house early
yeah so i i'm already uh saving for my
uh daughter's uh with a 529 and then uh
yeah i'm just working on paying off the
house right now man you guys are
crushing it alex teachers man they're
the they're the smartest i'm telling you
millionaire study teachers in the top
three top three there you go
unbelievable all right let's go to kevin
in denver hey kevin what's going on man
hey guys how are you doing excellent how
are you man
good thank you
hey got a quick question for you guys on
um we're working our our baby steps
right now have been since january
and
we've got two things to pay off one is
one vehicle
and the second is we have done solar
panels on our home so we want to pay
those off but
we have a few vehicles in the in the
family
and one of the vehicles is paid off i'm
not driving it i have the insurance
turned off
obviously to make some good money on it
right now um and by my calculations it
accelerates
you know getting out of the debt through
baby step two
by two three months but just looking for
kind of that confidence guidance on
should we sell that car or should we
keep it is it something special is it a
special car
no not a special car i mean it's it's um
you know it's a 2017
um i'm driving the old family uh minivan
right now so the plan was when we're out
of debt then
you know that would become my car again
but uh no nothing special so you don't
need this car at all
no no we've we've been very fortunate
and we've we've got uh
we've got five cars in the house well
we've got plenty you have five cars
well that changes this yeah i'm selling
that thing how much how much can you get
for it maybe private sales yeah i'm
thinking like
15 to 17 i think it's a 2017 so you can
get more for that on a 2017.
what kind of what kind of car is it's an
elantra sport okay it's the
what other special while we're selling
cars yeah so for sure sell this car what
else do you got laying around that you
can sell
well i i i do have a collector car but
that's not a good one so i'm gonna tell
you something crazy kevin and i i mean
hang on to your hats here
my wife and i each just have one car
and our life's pretty rad
is there a chance you could sell two or
three of these things and just really
escalate that how about you want to get
out of debt man
well i mean we yeah a bad i mean we were
well i mean not that bad not collectors
[Music]
no we have the minivan we have the her
car that hyundai
um and then
our boys each each have a vehicle oh
okay
you got teenage drivers
uh they're they're 20 and 22 one one
just finished school and and one is in
okay okay so i retract my s my smart
alecness i was yeah they're not like
just my wife and i's five cars just
kicking with five cars and you're
rocking the minivan yeah okay
no no no no i am rocking the minivan
how much debt is this total
um so so we have her car total is um
we have uh 17 left on her car which by
our budget will have will have paid off
by november okay um and then the solar
panels is is 32 000 right now but that
plan is to have that paid off by
next uh april or may so if you if you
sell this car you can pay off her car
and then you're down to just the solar
panels
exactly and so that's what i was looking
at today today you know
almost every day so just kind of
you know like wow it finds me two three
months but that's two three months of
being out of debt
today i always make fun of people for
that confirmation call but i'm one of
them now so
i appreciate the call and you're doing
the right thing here make sure you do
your research find out the true value of
this thing don't just give it away uh
for less than you can get for it so find
out you know dealerships trade-ins
whatever those things are sometimes
going to room or carvana will get you
just as much as a private sale so do
your research on this but try to get as
much money as you can to accelerate this
debt pay off and hey you
kevin you just said something i want to
make sure everybody heard that
that you know kevin's like man i listen
to the show all the time and i make fun
of those guys who those men and women
who call in for the confirmation call
that we know what y'all are going to say
but we call anyway just to clear the air
with everybody
behind when the microphones are off
i asked dave hey man i'm about to make
this purchase i'm moving my money to
this to that is that a smart move and
he's like yeah dave might ask me like
talking about marriages talking about
kids talking about stuff george you and
i talk about
other people are your emergency fund for
life and like the gentleman earlier who
walked into the bank who knows what he
wants to be debt-free he's got to cash
and the bank talks him out of it it's
easy to go into these situations when
there's this much cultural pressure that
says you should have a fico score you
should have debt you're an idiot for
paying things off you're you're dumb for
being debt-free
you're dumb for having a good marriage
you're dumb for communicating with your
kids not letting your kids have all
these entertainment systems you're dumb
for not being on social media you mean
your kids don't
if you are the only one
you're gonna feel isolated so it's
always good to check in with somebody
don't ever feel stupid for making a call
and checking in with somebody yeah and
there's so many voices that are in your
life speaking oh the bank says this my
mother-in-law said this and my brother
said to do this and sometimes you just
need one clear source that goes hey i'm
not a part of any of that and here's
what i would do if i was in your shoes i
i make that a practice of my life to
have people that i can call i've got a
buddy who's you know what i'm not a
plumber i know a guy i'm not a hvac guy
one of my best friends in the world is
the one of the executives at a hvac
company so if i have a i have a guy if i
want to know anything before the the i
mean after the 17th century i call
george campbell i love him just say tell
me about the shiny things
we'll be your guys call us up triple
eight eight two five five two two or
hesitate to call just to check in and
make sure you're on the right path
that's wisdom not dumb not idiotic it's
wisdom we'll be right back on the ramsay
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
55 of americans want to change jobs this
year
the struggle with burnout is real across
the country right now so much so that
they've even given this season of job
turnover a name the great resignation
but just like you need a plan for your
money you absolutely need a plan for
your career ask yourself what do i like
about my current job what do i not like
about my current job what does my dream
job look like what i need to do in order
to have my dream job
if it's time to make a change america's
career coach ken coleman has written out
his proven career plan and his brand new
book from paycheck to purpose
stop settling for just another paycheck
and find work that brings purpose and
joy into your life
the book plus a hundred bucks and free
tools we'll send you for pre-ordering
will help you find what you're meant to
do
and how to land your dream job
everyone needs to read this book before
changing jobs get your copy of from
paycheck to purpose today
at ramseysolutions.com
let's go to ryan in chicago what's up
brian how's it going
good how are you guys outstanding
brother what's up how can we help
so i currently um
on my baby step two
i'm making uh 71.5 at renewable energy
company
um
and i am
thinking of taking a pay cut down to 47
000
or doing a job that i really enjoy and
i've done before
but it definitely pays a lot less
and it would take me a while to get out
of baby step two
financially so
just kind of looking for some directions
on that
dude so um
what's up
man that's a big drop
that's a that's one of those what i call
like a snow globe shaker moments like
you are you're dumping things on its
head what do you what do you want to get
at your job so bad what do you hate
about your job
um
well i worked remotely and when i first
started i did love it
but
now it's kind of really isolating and i
don't really enjoy the work
um
i'm not using my hands i'm not building
things like i would like to
doing carpentry and stuff that i'm
actually really good at and could be
around people to mentor them and educate
them
at the other job
and at this job i just kind of feel like
i'm
you know doing doing the daily do and
making that paycheck so
how much how much debt do you have man
about 53 000 53 you married you get kids
what's your what's your life situation
nope i'm single
i rent i have a dog
that's about it
man
so tell me about this job you think you
want to move into
so the this job is
something i've done before
um it would be at a
community college working with students
to
help educate them on how to build
scenery for theater
i'd be using my hands i'd be working
up and walking around and
active
it's something i'm passionate about and
i love to do
um that i've done before and that i i
have a degree in
and i'm i actually know what i'm doing
very cool
so
again this is what a 23.5 about 24 000
pay
cut yeah right around 25. yeah
so
i'm going to talk out of both sides of
my mouth on this one okay and then i'm
just going to be honest with you and
tell you what i would do if i was in
your situation and you are free to move
about the country how you think it's
right
um and george man i'd love you to to hop
in here
um
you are in a season of life where you
have no obligations to anybody but
yourself right you know 53 grand i'm
assuming most of the student loans is
that right
student loan car and credit card yeah
okay
you're in a moment well let me back up
money um
this is a significant lifestyle change
both
towards something that you love being
around students helping them teaching
them helping them create you get to do
things that you love
especially in the theater department man
you get to that rush of performance
night
that's a total life change that sounds
incredible i mean it sounds awesome i've
i've done that with students i loved
that life
the other side of that is you have a
magic moment that you could clear this
debt in about a year if you chose to
you could get ferocious and clear this
thing off once and for all
and
so it's
what i'll tell you is i i can't tell you
the number of people i've talked to our
friend ken coleman has talked to over
and over and over that somebody took a
job for the money they didn't like it
they took it for the money and their
life ends up spiraling out on them
because it wasn't worth it it wasn't
worth that move that's where you found
yourself but you're already here so if
you were making 47.5 and you said hey i
love the work i love everything about
this i'm thinking about taking a job
that i'm not going to like at all but
it's going to be a 24 000 raise i would
tell you to think long and hard about
not doing that
about loving the life you're in
you're already there
and so if i'm you
i would put a calendar date and i would
reverse engineer that how fast and how
crazy could i get about paying this debt
off
and could i do this in a calendar year
could i do this in 18 months be done
with this forever and then i'm going to
start leaning into
my dream job
because what i don't want you to do is
to go take this job at a community
college you're going to love it they're
going to they're going to look at the
arts to make cuts first and you're going
to find yourself in 18 months you're
down to 50 000 or maybe 45 000 worth of
debt and then you're either looking for
a job or you're frustrated this debt is
moving off very slower than you thought
it was going to does that make sense
yeah that makes sense so what does life
look like if you just grit your teeth
and suck it up and just use this
high-powered salary you got dump another
job on top of it and just work like
crazy for the next 12 months and just
get this thing done does that feel
better than
packing up and moving and taking this
thing with you like a pet
it does and that that's kind of the side
i'm leaning towards because it does make
me nervous to
take that pay cut
um
and i've i've been grinding it out for
about a year now of when i realized that
you know this isn't i'm not enjoying
this
and i've just watched the debt go down
and down and down and it's been
encouraging
um but at what cost is that to you know
my my mental health and you bet and me
as a person so what i'll tell you in my
in my personal life i don't tell the
story very often
my wife and i
sold our house moved into a college
residence hall
and we paid off six figures worth of
debt in about 18 months and she was
working full-time i was basically
working three jobs two and a half jobs
and we lived spartan
and we had no bills it was a glitch in
the matrix
we ultimately the next year after we
paid it off took a 70 000 household
income pay cut to take a new job for the
reasons you just acknowledged for
community for my get my head screwed
back on straight to re-prioritize our
marriage and being parents
and what i will tell you is that year of
grinding it out for us when we were
laser beam focused and the checks we
were sending every month to student
loans were
wild
um they were more than our car that i
mean we were driving an old used car um
but i'll never
ever regret that year of a laser beam
focus at 18 months of laser beam focus
to get us to clear that nonsense once
and for all we've never looked back
and so i get you the pay cut hurts and
by the way when you live free and you
don't owe anybody any money then you can
really lean into your job be really good
at it say what you really think and then
people reward you for it and financially
we've we've recovered that
x fold right so if i'm you i'm gonna
spend one more year i'm gonna put on the
calendar i'm gonna make those little
cheesy rings or whatever i'm to put it
make it a destination i'm going to do
this and i'm going to be done with this
stuff forever and then i'm going to
start moving about the country but i'm
not going to knock you for
having this opportunity to do your dream
job what do you think george ryan if i'm
in your shoes i'm going to look at this
like i got a 25 000
raise to get rid of this debt fast so on
top of what you're doing now go do the
stuff you love to do and make money
doing it because you're in a place where
you can work with your hands you can
build sets you can do carpentry you
there's so much opportunity for you to
make money doing the stuff that you
already enjoyed doing on top of this
full-time job and let that dream fuel
you to get rid of this debt even faster
and if your car
is is worth something and you're not
going to be underwater on it sell that
thing and drive a beater and accelerate
this you'll find ways when you want this
dream badly enough and clearly you do so
i would i would uh suffer through this
next year and get a side job doing the
stuff that you enjoy doing whatever it
takes to get rid of this 53 000 in debt
so that you're freed up and you can make
47 and it doesn't bother you doesn't
bother you no payments that's exactly
right ryan you're in a good spot man i
want to see you go crush it crush it
crush it your mental health will rise as
you accomplish your goals and by the way
get some community man put yourself in a
position to be around other people hey
give us a shout triple 85-5225 we'll be
right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm john delonie joined by george
campbell and we are taking your life on
relationships mental health your
finances getting out of debt trying to
figure out what retirement vehicle is
best for you
all of it it's a little on in your house
and your home and your hearts everywhere
and we're here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
your show
and we're here to walk alongside you
some people
say the advice is worth what you pay for
it zero
just make sure that's clear it's free
this is free it's toll free triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
how's your world going man it's going
great john uh we had a great event last
night a lot coming up fine print is is
i'm having a blast with that podcast and
uh i'm just happy to be here with you
it's pretty rare we get to host together
so i'm trying to cherish it i know and
and ken coleman sits between the two of
us and so oh that's true our actual
desks to make it clear yeah yeah yeah
he's not underneath the desk right now
at our actual desks yes and um so yeah
it ends up we never get to talk we never
get to see each other we never hang out
except for this live in front of
everyone
it's a big moment before this gets any
weirder let's go to caleb in fort
lauderdale what's up caleb
hey how's it going how's it going guys
we're good brother what's up dude how
can we help
yeah man so i'm out here for fort
lauderdale florida i'm 21 years old i'm
a dad of a one-year-old i have a
girlfriend i'm running out of an
apartment for about like 1200 dollars
i'm in depth about i want to say um 20
yeah yeah about 20 grand
currently unemployed i've been doing
customer service for like the last three
four years
and really
my general question would be obviously
you know how to get out of depth uh you
know be debt free and i've been having
to do side jobs like ubereats and um
you know a couple of other side jobs
whatever i can find to be able to pay my
bills because really my expenses are
more than what i'm actually making
you're unemployed so you're making
basically zero right
yeah currently yeah i was just
unemployed yes i was laid off yesterday
um so now i'm kind of unemployed today
yeah correct
dude um
i'm sorry that happened that's no good
who who laid you out i mean not who not
the company but what'd you get laid off
from from customer service
say that again you got laid off from
your customer service job
all right well
this was a sales position but yeah okay
so
21
girlfriend kid
20 grand in debt just got laid off
and
you woke up today today feels heavy huh
yeah definitely definitely i mean i i've
been kind of watching you guys for a
little bit and uh oh my man i gotta i
gotta give him a call man i just don't
know what to do right now um you know
yeah yeah
so what
caleb what do you wanna do man
well um currently i mean i've been just
looking for jobs is you know like just
moving no no no no no no no no yeah i
got that i got that what do you want to
do
like like my future what what my dream
job is you're in a boat that has a big
hole in it and you've got a cup and
you're trying to bail the water out and
then you added a girlfriend then you
added a one-year-old
and then somebody dropped a bigger hole
in that boat and what you're looking
around for is another cup and what i'm
asking you is what boat do you want to
be in man two years from now five years
from now what do you want this thing to
look like down the road
stability man stability uh i know what
do you want to do free what do you want
to do well
i would like to become a a professional
trader i mean that's that's something i
really you know love doing you know
looking at charts and uh things like me
it may not be you know something like
everyone's you know dream or something
but i'd like to become a professional
trader
a trader trade like a stock trader
yeah correct like stock trade but yeah
so yeah i'm really into that
so what steps have you taken to become a
stock trader
well um i've done a lot of studying but
i know the biggest thing is if you want
to make money i mean you kind of have to
have money in order to trade and things
like that and i'm not going to be
borrowing money to trade or anything
like that so i'm trying to essentially
be able to build an account uh with
money you know saving that account to
then be able to go ahead and start
trading with little
little small sizes and you know be able
to grow my account long term you know
within the next 5-10 years
so can i be honest with you but
yes sir that's real close to a get rich
scheme
some kind of scam some kind of shortcut
to
try to dig yourself out of the hole that
you're in
now wanting to trade stocks wanting to
be an investment banker all that stuff's
great man but
when you've got a baby and a girlfriend
in an apartment
and
twenty thousand dollars in debt
trying to build your portfolio over
there on the side you see what i'm
saying
right
so
what what what things do you have here's
what
man you and i could talk for a while
um
here's what i'm worried about i'm
worried about you got a little baby
there you got a scared to death
girlfriend you have rent due
and you got to start figuring out a i
got to get some some money to go pay the
bills right now
whatever that looks like not one job not
two job but three jobs
and at the same time you're gonna have
to build some sort of you said i've been
doing some research
you can't just get on the internet and
google stuff about how to trade stocks
you need to go learn about what that is
you take some finance classes you need
to get in there and learn does that make
sense
right correct and so you've got to get a
game plan together that's going to be
both i need some cash right now which
means i just i got to suck up all my
pride all of it and get after it and i
got to make some stability plans with my
family and i got to start planning for
the future and brother you've got to do
this all at the same time which means
for the next two three four five years
you're gonna be tired you're gonna go to
bed exhausted because you're going to be
working your butt off you're going to
stay plugged into that kid you're going
to marry that girlfriend and you're
going to connect your family together
and you're going to start planting some
roots
does that sound
exciting does that sound like yeah
that's what i'm talking about or did
that make you be like nah bro i just
need to open an account i can make
trades
no that's because that sounds exactly uh
like what i'd love to do are you
currently day trading and stuff what's
going on on that side no no
no no no no i haven't i haven't traded a
dollar in my money nothing like that as
of yet
yeah how much cash do you want
what's your cash position do you have
any money
uh probably i mean to be quite honest
about like 800 bucks in my checking
account that's about it okay
so and what kind of debt is this 20 000
uh that's an auto loan uh i think that's
an auto loan and uh
yeah credit card are you under water on
the auto loan what's the car worth
versus what you owe
uh yeah the car is it's a fourth focus
i'm i'm i'm piola about like i think
like 13 at 13 and it's only worth like
nine so i am a little debt little down i
was thinking i mean i'm not sure if it's
a great idea possibly about turning in
the car and just paying whatever's left
on it
and just because because we do have a
second car that's paid off that you know
it's my girlfriend's mom she gave it to
her yeah i was just thinking about the
sticking
uh i mean at this point dude i'd rather
you take that car um it's it's not worth
a whole bunch of money 9 000 bucks isn't
i mean you're in a mess right now i'd
rather you take that car and start
scratching and clawing so this time
tomorrow you have a job somewhere
you've got a job somewhere to get some
sort of income coming in and then you're
gonna have a second job by the end of
this week and you're gonna start looking
at finance school local community
college classes you're gonna get plugged
in there and you and your girlfriend are
gonna go out and have a planning session
and figure out what tomorrow and next
month the next year is going to look
like
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
we're gonna go out to
great falls montana talk to joseph hey
brother joseph what's up
hello hey hey we're here are you yes sir
what's up man how can we help
well i wanted to find out we would like
to try to do an airbnb in our basement
we have a basement that's kind of
separated from the rest of the house
and wanted to see if home equity line of
credit would be something that would be
good to do
if i had a big buzzer i would hit it
right now
joseph what do you think you know what
show you're calling
i do
walk me through what
well we're trying to we have a basement
that's not completed it needs some
finishing
and so we're trying to uh figure out a
way in order to do that
uh with the current budget that we have
are you unable to cash flow this over
the next x amount of months
as you're talking about as far as
monthly payments go no no i'm talking
about could you pay for this renovation
in cash what would that take and how
long
well we have not got a firm figure yet
from the contractor so i don't know
we're just estimating based on
the little bit we know about renovations
and
uh it would take
we'd i'm not sure what it would take
it'd probably take at least a year to a
year and a half i'm guessing to set
aside to do the renovation
so here's what i'm thinking
i want you to pay cash for this
obviously i don't know is there a sense
of urgency driving this airbnb thing or
is this just you guys got excited about
making some extra income
pretty much just excited about making
extra income so if there's no urgency
here i want you to do this at the speed
of cash and i want you to also think
about the roi
look at the market for airbnb in the
great falls area what are people willing
to pay for a a basement apartment for a
night in your area and then go okay
based on all of that plus the expenses
the fees that airbnb takes of the
cleaning all of that stuff how long is
it going gonna take me to recoup my
investment that i made in cash
okay once you do that you can start to
reverse engineer this thing and you go
okay it's gonna cost us 20 grand to get
this basement in good shape we don't
have to go crazy and uh we can put two
grand a month towards this so in 10
months we're gonna cash flow this thing
and then all of the money that comes in
from that airbnb is yours and it's not
going to pay off this stupid heloc so
that's that's the right way to do it uh
and by the way 20 grand probably it's
more like probably like 100 right just
what do you think this is any general
estimates
well we're thinking between 30 and 50
depending on uh the materials that they
use or the grade that we go with i was
closer john i was like price is right i
win the prize without going over
joseph here's my concern
is
i'm just going to make something up out
of thin air here let's pretend that we
had a global pandemic say
and let's say that travel just shut down
and you've got this beautifully
renovated home
that you now owe debt against your house
the most important asset you own
you've now leveraged against the
basement
and you have no income coming in on it
that's my favorite
and
i'd much rather see you and your wife
get firm numbers that you can create a a
true real budget with
and set up a cash flow because here's
what you're going to do you're going to
get real excited about this and you're
going to work your butts off to get that
that cash or
you're going to stop watching so much
hdtv and this is going to be less of a
cool you know what i mean it's not gonna
be quite as cool as you thought
hey and be honest with me while i got
you did you watch some awesome bob villa
episode and you're like i think we can
do this is that oh i've done that
several times and done it yeah i could
tell he was a vela fan dude i know man
it's i i go down this rabbit hole myself
like oh dude i could just i woke up yeah
it's gonna be incredible i just need to
get thirty thousand dollars i got this
much equity in my house don't do it
don't do it don't set yourself up to
lose your home over your basement yeah
and on paper you go oh my gosh this
airbnb is gonna make us so much money so
it's totally worth it to take out the
heloc we're gonna pay this thing it'll
be great and then life happens and then
great falls is gonna pass an ordinance
that says we don't do airbnb anymore and
you're gonna say well wait wait wait a
minute or they're gonna say you can't
have guests or they've gotta have this
or you can only have vaccinated guests
so it's gonna cut your
your population your people your
customer base in half or whatever it's
gonna look like
pay cash pay cash pay cash and then if
you pay cash and they and suddenly life
happens
then you can go sleep down in the
basement in this new place joseph and uh
you won't owe anybody any money on it
let's go to logan in louisville kentucky
what's up logan how are we doing brother
uh how you doing can you hear me yes sir
we can how's how's it going
uh how's it going it's going pretty good
uh hey guys i have a little bit of a
weird one for you guys so i'm 19 and my
friend's also 19 and i started listening
to dave ramsey about a year ago and
since then uh i i went in and i so i
work at two jobs i work at a kentucky
truck plan i work at ford and then also
just work a little side job and we live
in a van both of us and we both work two
jobs we've saved up about 20 000 over
the course of like this year doing this
and we're just trying to like i'm really
concerned about my future i don't want
to go into debt so like i don't have any
debt neither one of us and we just want
to know where do we put this money do we
put in roth iras do we put this on state
like uh maxing out my 401k at work where
do i put this money
so i'll let george into that but let me
is this a romantic interest or is this
just you and like like a roommate no
this is yeah no this is like a friend
yeah this is just me and a friend of my
roommate okay so i would first say don't
speak in terms of we when it comes to
y'all's money
okay just yeah y'all aren't doing y'all
aren't building wealth together you
aren't saving money together this your
right your van mate will have money and
you'll have money so this is your
individual money okay don't don't
ghostbusters one man don't cross the
streams here okay
okay so
you said there's a side business are you
talking about twenty thousand dollars is
from the side business that you guys do
together
no no no so basically now we just we've
always just said that the money is just
like we've always just put the money
together there is no side business it's
just two jobs why are you putting the
money together
well just because like
honestly i don't know we just we've just
been friends for so long since you know
real real young and this has just been
i'm good friends with john but we don't
put our money together it's like bill
and ted's one and two like we're gonna
get married together and yeah
again i got great great friends that
i've had my whole life that's awesome um
you guys are scrappy 19 year olds
sharing a van you got no expenses again
not how i would do it but high five to
you man um
but yeah when it comes to sharing money
one of you is going to meet somebody one
of you is going to get another job and
want to move out and untangling that's
going to be chaos you're going to lose a
friend over this that's right and i
don't want that for you so you you've
been listening to the show for a year so
you you know the baby steps so do you
have any debt currently either of you no
no no yeah and do you have any emergency
savings do you have a fully funded
emergency fund
well i mean twenty thousand twenty
thousand dollars we have and i'm
guessing okay so you personally how much
money do you have that's where this gets
real confusing right because you're
saying i don't personally have twenty we
have twenty how much of that is
a lot of yours
we would just cut out i'd say 10. i
would literally just cut it like so i'm
guessing 10 000 is three to six months
of expenses for you or more
oh yeah way more oh yeah okay and yeah
at that point you'd be at baby step four
where you can begin investing the bigger
question here is what is your long-term
future what do you mean do you want to
be in a van for the next five years
well not maybe not like i mean yeah
probably honestly yeah five years
doesn't sound bad maybe not 10 i
wouldn't like to push it like past that
but yeah i just i want to like be able
to have a big you know like uh dave's
always talking about you know having
buying or you know having like a you
know a wealth building tool and you know
your income is your biggest wealth
building tool and you just got to free
up everything so i thought well what was
the best way you know gazelle intensity
what was the best way to like free up
all my expenses okay just live in a van
and then get somebody else in here and
then if we're both doing it and you know
we're both going hard at two different
jobs i don't know what we're pretty
selfless people as far as like each
other but i can definitely see how that
would like be a problem like
like you know the money situation but
yeah in my head it's always been
i just want you to have a vision for
your future and get a great job that you
love and a career that you can sink your
teeth into uh aside from the van yeah
and
man you are a scrappy 19 year old
brother on a high five you
i'm i'm
further down the road than you are and i
want to also pass along the importance
of a good night's sleep
of a shower
of some stability and so this might be a
six month plan this might be a nine
month plan
get a one bedroom apartment a cheap
one-bedroom apartment that you can begin
to have some stability invite some
friends over and build a future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from bella in california
i have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in school loans my fiance has no
debt and has more than that amount and
savings for a house down payment
we've been together for five years i
believe my loans are setting us back on
marriage and buying a home together
he prioritizes his quote financial
planning more than the progress of our
relationship
i'm working my butt off to pay these
loans while he has the cash to help me
and ultimately us he insists on holding
on to the down payment money instead of
helping me
he says he wants to marry me but i feel
that his timeline is not very timely i
need perspective on whether i am right
in all of this
george you've been married sooner than
me what are your thoughts on this well i
feel like this is less of a financial
question and more of a relationship
question i don't like this idea of he's
prioritizing financial planning over our
relationship and i want to know if i'm
right or and if he's wrong these are
just backwards ways of thinking about
this relationship and uh i think i think
both of them are wrong and in some ways
i think
they need to have a wee mentality if
they're about to get married and these
loans are about to become his loans and
their loans instead of well that's her
thing
and i've got my money here that i've
worked so hard for now she's screwing
all this up
that attitude is going to hurt them
in marriage
bell yeah this this is there's a big
giant flashing red sign
saying stop danger ahead
and
i know you love this guy and i'm
confident that he loves you
but y'all are living parallel lives and
parallel tracks and you are trying to
combine lives combined futures you are
hitching your wagon to this guy and him
to you
but you're trying to do it halfway
and so before anybody takes any more
steps you only need to get in with a
premarital counselor
today tomorrow asap
um this is a recipe for
a disaster an absolute disaster um
you're not on the same page financially
you're not on the same page relationally
you're not on the same page
for supporting one another um earlier in
one of the breaks i got a question on on
social media somebody asked me um like
some secret tips of marriage i asked
george and um
he said out serve each other that's
exactly right
and this one is out ernie y'all trying
to out earn each other try to out
compete each other out work your butts
off for each other and this is just the
backwards way into a marriage backwards
way
by the way this question right here i
need perspective on whether i am right
in all of this not what to do but
whether i'm right let me be super clear
if you have an argument with your spouse
or your fiance and one of you wins
you both lose
arguments in marriage are not to be won
or lost they're
you're not at war in competition with
your spouse with your fiance you're both
the problem is the problem the challenge
is the problem you're trying to solve
something together not win against one
another and if you find yourself in
competition
i want to know if i'm right i think he's
wrong
you are on dangerous ground man john i
can count on zero fingers how many times
i have won an argument with my wife and
it brought us closer together
zero no zero never so here's my thing if
i'm in their shoes and they ca they can
get on the same page
what i don't want is for him to be
resentful because he had all this money
and i paid off the loans instantly as
soon as they got married and now he's
resentful because like all this i worked
so hard for this and she took it all
away
it's going to create a lot of resentment
now that's the right thing to do
financially because now you are one and
her debt is your debt
but i don't want this to create
resentment and i feel that like that's
what's going to happen if he does this
yeah and if it doesn't it's going to
create resentment on her part because
she's stuck paying her loans and he's
going gonna go i'm not paying your loans
i'll get us the house because that's my
thing but i'm not touching your debt and
then she lives in quote unquote his
house as his wife
as the the
mother of the children that home
they're all living in his house yep
because you've got this debt you're
working on it's a dangerous situation
this is not heading down a good road
already so
they need to get on the same page or
other otherwise this is not going to
work regardless of the finances all
right let's go to melissa in richmond
virginia hey melissa what's going on
hi good afternoon
george and dr d i appreciate you all
taking my call of course what's up
i'm going to make this quick because i
have a lot
to um
to disperse but
i have
i take i took a job um
i obtained a new job a position that i
had wanted to take
and do anything that i wanted to do um i
tell me a male dominant field however i
feel like that i am still feeling the
symptoms from my old job of being burnt
out
of being um
not included
and when i've shown my passion i've
shown that i want to be included and
allow the desire
and for some reason i think that with
everything else that's going on i'm
finalizing the divorce i'm not being
able to co-parent properly with my son's
father
i walked out on that job
and i don't know why i well i know why
but i that's not my that was not my
character yeah and i feel so bad about
it
and so i'm just wondering what's going
through baby step two i was in the midst
of that
how do i get the motivation to
not take what i've learned or what i've
experienced in the past to a new
opportunity and i definitely don't want
to make i don't want god to be mad at me
that i have
not being um
grateful for this opportunity and new
job things that i have been wanting to
do for years and never got a chance to
and i just feel so bad about it and i
don't know how where what to do from
from here
melissa thanks for sharing that
um you're in a you are in a storm
you're in a tough season
and a tough season a loss tough season
of figuring out what's up and what's
down and
one of the temptations we have sometimes
when
we get hit by a tsunami of life is we
make it a character issue i should have
been able to swim better
should have been able to hold my breath
longer
and i don't want you to look in the
mirror and see a defeated broken person
okay you're in a tough season it's
winter right now where you are
the sun will come out again
okay
um so some quick math here are you
unemployed now or when you said you
walked out on your job did you just walk
out and you're going to go back tomorrow
what's your employment status
no
um
you know i
i don't think that you know
i'll be going back because
um they you know i mean i haven't yet
heard from from hr um she sent me an
email i i sent her an email but she
haven't responded to what i sent her
so um i don't i don't think so because
i'm just i don't think that things will
be better at that job you know
i'm a very analytical person so i was
analyzing do you have money for food and
rent
well i'm gonna have to use my emergency
fund probably for my rent
you know because i definitely and i i
just moved here around the time i
started the new job so
so here's what i don't want you to do i
don't want you to make a your body is in
fight or flight you're
exhausted and will you use the word
burned out um
we're going to
i want you to pick up a copy of the
nagoski sisters book burnout it's a
remarkable book that helps people walk
through
when their body takes over in order to
keep them safe you're going through a
divorce you're messing with your kids
you're in a new town all these things
are circling around you
but i don't want you to lose sight of
you still got to eat and pay rent
and i know it feels like you are so
cooked right now and you i just i got to
get away from everything and i get that
but you're going to wake up in 48 hours
and you're not going to have money to
eat
and it may be too late
if it's possible and you are safe
go back to work
and
make that a part of your recovery part
of your healing journey
oh yes definitely i'm not the one to be
still i i know i know i know i know and
i don't want you to hear that as a
character thing i want you to hear that
as
you have a heart and a body that is
trying to keep you safe in the middle of
a storm
and you've got to deal with the
realities i got to eat you will have a
moment for your dream job you'll have a
moment for finding out the best thing
that's gonna best meet your skills
that's not today
today is you're gonna enter in a season
of healing
it's gonna be a year or two you're gonna
enter into a season of peace
but you gotta pay your bills along the
way and if they'll have you back and the
job is safe i want you to go back and
get that job and i want you to
start your healing journey find a
counselor find a pastor and get on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is psalms 9
10.
those who knew your name trust in you
for you lord have never forsaken those
who seek you
rosalyn carter says you have to have
confidence in your ability and then be
tough enough to follow through
that's a great quote you have to have
confidence in your ability and then be
tough enough to follow through let's go
to johnny in utah hey johnny what's up
brother
ah not a lot how are you guys doing
today good man how are you
good uh thanks for taking my call um
my question kind of falls more on the
category of some of the other calls
earlier today where it's kind of more of
a confirmation uh
i have a credit card that doesn't have a
balance on it i'm debt-free you know all
that good jazz and
i just have a fundamental value to it i
just um just can't seem to get rid of it
is it cute
well i wish it was it make you feel safe
why can't you get rid of it why is it
sentimental
uh just because it's like i didn't
really have you know growing up i didn't
really have a
you know support system and all that and
so um
there was a time in my life and i had a
lot of debt and i had to have it so to
say
but i'm not there anymore now you know
thankfully i'm good financially healthy
uh financially healthy
yeah so tell me about
you had to have it tell me about that
uh well
originally um when i started kind of
second dead on it it was just more of
like
you know i needed it for rent i was just
i was going out of a bad relationship at
the time
um
but but why did you need that credit
card for rent why'd you need like you're
coming out of a bad relationship why did
you need a credit card to help exit a
bad relationship
i just pretty much should be able to
i didn't want to leave my partner
hanging at the time so i had to cover
that half of the rent and then you know
find a new place and at the time i just
didn't have the money for it so young
and dumb but
so but what i'm trying to get you to is
you didn't need it
but it helped you do things that you
wanted to do
is that fair yeah
yeah that'd be a fair assault spot okay
okay
and i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
poke at you or anything like that what
i'm trying to do is is
you've got some tight emotion this thing
is wound into you somehow
and it sounds like it's wound into
the
the the the
dissolution of a relationship that meant
something to you of a tough season in
your life
and it's become a security blanket it's
become something that you hang on to as
a just in case of a just in case
and so what i'm trying to unwind here is
you don't need it like you need air or
water
you don't even need it financially are
you out of debt now
yes sir i am yeah man do you have an
emergency fund
i do six months brother that should be
sentimental not a piece of plastic that
a company printed out and their name on
it yeah
would you cut it up on the phone with us
or is that too hard for you
what was that would you ever cut this
card up on the phone right now while
we're on the line
uh
you said you needed confirmation so you
know what you need to cut it right now i
don't know
but yeah i'll basically get rid of it no
no no no you have it on you you love it
you have it i pictured you holding it
while you called us or on a necklace
pull it out and cut it up
dude cut it up today you can call him up
and cancel and tell him dave ramsey told
you to do whatever you got to do but you
need to get this out of your life you're
in a different place you work so hard to
get out of debt and you know you're
never going back again
let that be sentimental the hard work
your never again moment where you said
never again am i gonna have to rely on a
credit card to pay rent
you've done so much hard work to get to
this point and now
you're sentimental over a literal piece
of plastic just take the emotion out and
just look at it logically a company
printed out a piece of plastic and gave
you money
not as a gift but so that they could
make money off of you i want you to get
angry at this company angry at this card
cut it up put it in an ornament put it
on your christmas tree how's that for
sentimental
i probably won't put it on three but
like yeah definitely but you're keeping
in your wallet there's not much of a
difference is there yeah or cut it up
and mail it to us cut it up and set it
in a fire i like that idea john will
shoot it
i'm not going to shoot it but
here's the thing you know what you need
to do and i i will i'll honor the fact
that this thing has woven itself into
you but as george said i want you to
flip that connection around
it is not something that's kept you safe
it's something that's kept you trapped
it's something that's kept you enslaved
be angry at this thing that has grown
roots into your soul and it's time for
it to go and you've done all the hard
work already
call it and cancel it
do we have your word in front of the
entire country today's the day
yesterday's the day
i don't want it anymore
it's awesome today's the day today's the
day you are free my brother
congratulations i'm excited that's
awesome congrats man all right let's
take one more let's go to ethan and
toledo hey ethan what's up brother how's
it going
hey better than i could possibly earn
brothers how are you same here same here
how can we help man
um
proverbs says that in the multitude of
counselors there is safety so i'm just
calling to see what your guys's thoughts
are
um
if
you know we got baby step one thousand
dollars baby step two
is where we're at and if we believe
that it's going to take
like 10 to 20 years in baby step 2
because um
just because the debt is so many times
20 years
yeah so if that's if it's if it's going
to take that long
um do you have a million dollars in debt
what's your debt load no no no
no no there's definitely
things that can be done how much do you
owe let's talk numbers here
all right how much did go quick because
we're going to get up against the clock
here how much you owe yeah so
say 400 000
you owe 400 000
yeah okay income of 60.
what kind of debt is this 400
mostly student loans
what'd you go to school for
uh
uh i'm actually calling for a friend um
i think it was
like psychology
and criminal justice i don't but there's
like several degrees involved
um
so so this isn't your debt or your money
that you're calling on behalf of a
friend
that's correct
okay
well
this is a
big hole and a very little shovel
they answer your question ethan
ethan the answer to question is no
the answer is no you don't need a bigger
emergency fund is that what you're about
to ask okay
yeah no what you need is a thousand
dollars for like one to three years
but i'm wondering if it's gonna take
you know you need to get a job that pays
more than 60 thousand dollars
and if you've got this
hold on if you got this type of student
loans and this many degrees you need to
figure that one out you need a much
bigger shovel
the answer is not to skimp on the
plan this is a catastrophe this is a
world-class
um
emergency room
fiasco
financially
there is no safety here there is no 5
000 emergency funds not going to keep
you any safer
400 000 against 60.
you need a way way way bigger shovel
because you're in a big big big big big
hole and although well we just can't you
got to figure it out they need to be
working three or four jobs for five
years to clean this mess up yeah and the
accident an action is being taken toward
increasing the income i just wondered
like is there a is there a year
threshold where you would say yeah it's
probably wise to do more than
more than a thousand i know because five
years is it i don't want you punting off
five years i want you figuring this out
way way sooner
way way sooner
what's the average george it takes when
somebody gets serious about this thing
18 to 24 months and the average time it
takes the average person to pay off
student loans is 20 years but we're not
doing average here we're going gazelle
intense this person needs to live their
life that's right you need to tell their
friend they need to get four jobs
and they need to cut whatever they've
been doing with their life and start to
make some smart decisions and that
doesn't include having a year supply of
emergency fund that's not the issue here
i want to thank james childs and kelly
daniel
thank you america for listening to us
and for joining us right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you